her coroner has concluded that the
online material viewed by Molly Russell
was not safe and shouldn't have been
available for a child to see the parents
of the 14 year old have been campaigning
for better internet safety after the
schoolgirl took her own life in November
2017. today the children's commissioner
for England Dame Rachel de Souza told
the tech Giants to get a moral compass
well she joins us this evening good
evening to you good to have you with us
I I understand you've been working on
some public research and amongst the
results of that it showed that 45 of
children aged 8 to 17 are seeing
upsetting and worrying harmful content
absolutely Simon I mean we we
interviewed 2 000 children and their
parents
um and basically they were between the
ages of 8 and 17.
um 60 of the under the twelve eight to
twelve the underage were on social media
um 90 plus percent of the the children
13 plus were
um and 45 of them had seen really
worrying and disturbing material
including sexualized content pornography
bullying and trolling self-harm extreme
dieting and the parents their parents
told us just how worried they are about
this I mean over 70 of them had
um were using parental controls and the
children were still seeing this stuff
and and I mean even when they reported
it for 25 of them who reported it
nothing happened so I really am calling
for the social media Giants to step up
and sort this out for once and for all
the molly muscle case is a wake-up call
for us and I just want to say how my
heart goes out to her father Ian Russell
who's campaigned so hard for this like
no father should ever have to experience
yeah absolutely it is shocking but sadly
not surprising statistics and just bear
with us we've had a statement in from
the Prince of Wales about this he's just
released this statement saying no parent
should ever have to endure what Ian
Russell and his family have been through
they have been so incredibly Brave
Online safety for our children and young
people needs to be a prerequisite not an
afterthought Dane Rachel de Souza your
reaction to that
so I cannot agree more I have 100 agree
with that statement so now it's time for
the social media companies to step up
they need to remove the self-harm and
suicide content they know where it is
they can do this they've been doing
better lately but they really need to
get grips with this and they need proper
age Assurance they they should at the
bottom of the Molly Russell case were
these were these algorithms now if
you're looking at dogs or cats on the
site the algorithm will send you more
dogs than cats but if you let's see a
self-harm post and and click on it then
it doesn't matter what age you are
you're going to get this material pushed
your way this has to stop for under 18s
I mean and that was what I was talking
about when I said these companies need
to get a moral compass it is not right
for this you know they've had the chance
to self-regulate for so long how many
more children need to die how many more
children need to suffer like this
um so it really does have to stop and
and that's why backing the online harms
bill on the children at child element
um because I think self-regulation
hasn't worked with these companies and
we need to get some tough laws in to
protect our children do you think the
Online safety bill goes far enough
though because it doesn't include
criminal uh proceedings if anything goes
wrong and and frankly if you if you look
at the kind of fines we're talking about
for a company like meta which is a multi
I think 118 billion dollar company that
fines in the millions are virtually
irrelevant to them absolutely I mean
there was talk at one point of actually
finding named Executives
um you know and actually the people in
charge not for you know and imprisoning
them that I I I think it can't can't go
far enough so I'm really Keen to see the
Online safety build back but you know
why can we not you know why can these
companies not take this stuff down now
they have the technology
yeah Dame de Souza Instagram has said
that it's doing its utmost to try and
protect young people in fact we've had a
a response from meta I'm just going to
uh briefly read it out so our viewers
have it um in response um uh it says
that uh we we're committed to ensuring
that Instagram is a positive experience
for everyone particularly teenagers and
will carefully consider the coroner's
full report when he provides it
um it goes on we'll continue our work
with the world's leading independent
experts to help ensure that the changes
we make offer the best possible
protection and support for teens is that
enough
look I meet the the six big tech company
leaders of the six big tech companies
every six months they agreed to meet me
and I constantly ask them how many
children have you got online are you
taking this material down they
constantly try to evade my questions
they are not doing enough
um and I honestly think we're seeing
merely moused responses as I've said
before we need them to get a moral
compass to sort this out now they can do
it it's despicable to think that they
put profits ahead of children's safety I
say this as a mother as an as someone
who's been a head teacher and a teacher
of the years I've seen the suffering
that children have been to I through on
this I do not want to see another child
harmed or die
um there is no you know there is no kind
of worthy words are not good enough we
want action now I mean it does seem
extraordinary doesn't it because people
like you and I and everyone I speak to
at home whom I have teenage nieces and
nephews there's a lot of concern about
teenager safety online and yet this
continues on Instagram Pinterest
Facebook and the like and people like
Francis Haugen who we're speaking to
later here on Sky News have also
highlighted this it's not just about the
algorithms that are sending more content
their way it's about the content being
on there in the first place and and they
know full well about it would you like
to see heads of these companies being
arrested if there are criminal
proceedings
absolutely I mean I I I I I think
because it's on the online online world
we often sort of just don't think about
it especially like my generation that
didn't grow up with this technology and
I can tell you parents are deeply
concerned and don't really understand
you know how to protect their children
properly because because actually one of
the key things that our research showed
was that even when parents were using
parental controls and really trying
their best children were still seeing
this material it's it's I mean it can't
be more simple than they've got to take
it down and they've got to be held to
account if they don't take it down and
we need a really good complaints
procedure for children at the moment
when children see this material they can
go online to report it and it's like
it's in a like an online form 50 of the
children who've seen the material didn't
even bother reporting it because they
thought they'd get no response
um nobody cared come on that's not good
enough so I mean I actually think to the
internet
um have an age restriction in the same
way that we see for films for example
well we do so so you know children
should not be on social media these
social media sites most of them have an
age age
a thing of 13 and yet we found 7 to 12
year olds you know a huge proportion of
them 60 of them were already on there
um now
um a good age Assurance would stop them
accessing it again we have the
technology now to put a proper age gate
on these sites but also you know the the
companies can see what what children are
viewing and make really good assessments
about their age they need to use those
tools I honestly truly and having worked
with them on a regular basis think that
profits have been put ahead of
children's safety and it's just not good
enough and and you know we cannot afford
to lose another young person's life and
I mean it's really interesting to me as
well that the psychiatrist in the Molly
Russell case said he viewed
um the material that she'd been viewing
and she was depressed and she was
looking at self-harm Material she was
liking thousands and thousands of of
this sort of self-harm material he
viewed it and he couldn't sleep he was
really Disturbed I've seen these images
they're really very disturbing and I
mean just to bring this home to you I
was talking to a room full of 14 to 15
year olds the other day I talked to like
hundreds of children and get their
responses on this so I thought class of
14 to 15 year olds two-thirds of them
had been sent beheading videos I mean I
think parents would be shocked
absolutely shocked by the kinds of
things that their children are accessing
and they're not even seeking it so again
this material needs taking down I think
we need strong legal protection for
children a proper complaints procedure
but as I said I want that I want the
companies to step up and sort take this
stuff down now just do it just show some
moral backbone we're going to have to
leave it there Dane Rachel de Souza
thanks very much indeed and I do just
want to say if anyone is affected by the
conversation we've just had you can
contact the Samaritans the phone number
is one one six one two three and if you
don't want to speak you can also email
Joe at samaritans.org